hot breath uh wayne flake jr asks
do you have any techniques when writing
um well i can write quicker now just
because i've been doing it a long time
so initially what i learned was
write out the whole story write out the
whole idea
then start removing what isn't funny you
know for example if the joke is about a
guy crossing the street
and you write i was walking across
hollywood boulevard on a rainy night
it's like
well are we going to talk about
hollywood or rain if not
i was just walking across the boulevard
at night you know what i mean so you get
to it quicker
now i've been doing it so long that that
i
tend to write quicker you know and and
the bad thing about that though is
sometimes i'm not descriptive enough
in my writing and uh so you find the
balance you find this is what we talk
about about your voice
how you write it the way you would say
it just like if you work as a
professional writer
okay if you're a joke writer for people
i have a friend named suli mccullough he
writes for a ton of comics he writes for
jamie foxx he writes for anthony
anderson he writes for
uh the wayans brothers etc he can write
in each of their voices because he knows
how
jamie delivers how anthony delivers etc
so you develop that for your own voice
and when you say being descriptive
enough is that like you're talking about
being on hollywood boulevard is it
talking about
details within like the weather or the
people around you what kind of
what kind of like descriptive language
are you talking well um
i'll give you a couple of examples okay
one example entirely taboo now
but if you go back and listen to bill
cosby tell a story
if you watch himself by bill cosby
you will see a master storyteller giving
funny details but painting an entire
picture with words
and that's how to do it uh fluffy gabe
iglesias
is very good at that because gabe gives
voices
to a bunch of different things or all of
his little friends in the story and
stuff like that
so they they paint a picture with the
words
you know that which is great and i'm not
that
they're very descriptive in their
storytelling storytelling comics
are like that and very good at doing
that um
then you have again like like me or like
if you watch
uh chappelle does it chappelle chappelle
and uh louis black do something that i
watched that that i
love and i i try to do it myself but you
got to be really confident to do that
this they will explain what they're
talking about they will take time to
explain it
and then make it funny on on chappelle's
i think
one of his netflix specials one of the
more recent ones he did a thing about
emmett till
and he explained who emmett till was and
what happened for those who don't know
emmett till was a 14 year old from
chicago went to visit
family in mississippi because he was
from chicago he didn't know all the
segregation rule blah blah
he was accused of looking at a white
woman they beat him to death and hung
him
and and it's a very heavy topic and it's
a very famous
picture because his mother showed his
body
so that the world would see this is what
they did to a 14 year old child
well uh dave told that whole
story to set up what he wanted to talk
about
now as a comic that takes a lot of
bravery and courage because you can see
just how the mood
changed when i just told it right now to
do that
and then go into comedy about it was
amazing
but that's that's the best in the world
and the confidence he has to do it you
know what i mean so
um when you talk about
using words to paint a picture or set up
a situation
lewis black will talk about some
congressman you haven't heard of passing
a bill
and he'll explain oh this congressman is
from
you know blah blah blah and this and
that and he'll make fun of the town
they're from and what the are they
thinking and this and that and then
he'll go into his joke
you know that takes a certain confidence
because you're taking time out
you have a limited time on stage and
you're taking time out
to explain something to make it funny so
it takes time to that confidence to do
that
um you and again you'll find your style
your style is going to be somewhere
between
that and between a quick setup punch
kind of joke
and when we're thinking about talking in
your voice on stage
uh charles chimed in with like what is
your favorite method of rehearsal
and do you rehearse your jokes out loud
to kind of
find your voice within the words no
not anymore not anymore that was a long
time ago
uh now my rehearsals are on stage you
know that
early on when you start out uh i tell
comics you gotta memorize your your five
minutes your six minutes your three
minutes whatever
backwards and forward because when
you're new and you're nervous and you
get on stage
the first thing it goes is your memory
and you forget what you were gonna say
and then you start stammering or
whatever
but but i mean you know i've been doing
this for 27 years my brain is so trained
to remember and sometimes i forget
whenever you walk off stage
any comic walks off stage we're thinking
about the joke we forgot to tell
the bit we forgot to do but it is just
the nature of the beast you know you
you so i don't rehearse i don't rehearse
as far as trying to memorize it off
stage i will
write a set list and try to memorize a
set list and when i do tv
i'll definitely try to stick to the set
list and
um yeah but otherwise no i don't
rehearse
the rehearsal like if i'm doing a tv
spot the rehearsal
is the 10 comedy club spots leading up
to the tv spot
mm-hmm